if you're already aware unreal engine 5
has come out and it is as the name
expected unreal now the quality of
unreal engine is far better than you
what you'd expect from any other
rendering engine and that's what makes
this video today so special what's going
on guys my name is david thomas welcome
back to the channel today i'm going to
be going through unreal engine 5
comparing it to twin motion and giving
you my first impressions on the software
now by absolutely no means am i an
expert in unreal engine 5 i've spent all
weekend just trying to figure it out
trying to get the best quality
information to be able to actually
compare these two softwares and
understand if it's worth investing a
serious amount of time into learning
unreal engine 5. that's exactly what
we're going to be breaking down today
step by step for the fundamental areas
of architectural visualization that you
might be considering important to you
before you decide on a key software to
commit to now both of these images
before you are either from twin motion
or unreal engine 5. both have been
curated in a very similar style very
similar manner one took about an hour to
create one took the entire weekend to
get something resembling something half
decent now there is a vast difference in
quality between these two images and if
you look closely you will see that
straight away and that's exactly why
we're talking about unreal engine 5
because it's that next step up from twin
motion into architectural photo realism
rendering but let's take a step back
unreal engine 5 is a very easy to
install software so is twin motion you
just download the unreal engine
downloader and you click download the
difference is unreal engine takes almost
a day to download because it is massive
and by the time you add all the plugins
that you're looking to actually get it
takes even longer whereas twin motion
takes about an hour to download about an
hour to install so two hours completely
done and dusted you're up and ready to
go
not to mention when you open unreal
engine 5 it takes a solid couple of
minutes just to boot up so even with a
high-end pc like the one behind me it
still takes a serious amount of power to
actually boot whilst twin motion is
pretty simple it's pretty lightweight
and can load relatively quickly the new
interface of unreal engine 5 makes it so
much cleaner so much more enjoyable to
use than unreal engine 4. i remember
comparing unreal engine 4 a long time
ago and it was just so cluttered so
messy and so much information that was
completely overwhelming to anybody
looking to start in unreal engine
whereas now unreal engine 5 is so much
cleaner however having said that there
is still an abundance of information and
settings that you can change and
manipulate exactly how you want now is
this a good thing is this a bad thing i
don't know maybe for a game developer it
is phenomenal but for somebody looking
to just do architectural visualization
it is incredibly over complicated for
almost no reason at least in my opinion
something as simple as changing the
scale on a material took me a enormous
amount of time to actually understand
and be able to manipulate in unreal
engine 5. what should be as simple as it
is in twin motion literally just
dragging a slider up and down
actually ended up in a rabbit hole on
youtube trying to figure out how to
actually code this into the back end to
be able to scale a specific material so
unreal engine 5 definitely has a
significantly larger learning curve than
i would have expected and a
significantly larger learning curve than
twin motion so as we stand in the
beginning
unreal engine 5 takes so long to
download and it takes so long to learn
whereas twin motion is a quick and easy
to understand program and installs in
the blink of an eye nonetheless there is
a vast difference between these two
softwares like i said at the start the
two images i showed you are miles apart
in quality twin motion can export some
relatively decent images especially if
you put some time and effort into it
however unreal engine can export unreal
images even without any effort so a
novice like me was able to export that
image that i've showed you on the screen
and it was significantly higher quality
than anything i've ever exported out of
twin motion not only was i able to
export a raw file to be able to give me
significant dynamic range abilities and
manipulations in lightroom i was also
able to control a full cinematic camera
now to this day you don't have that
ability in twin motion it might make an
appearance in the future but for the
time being all you can export is your
basic jpegs and png files when you're
looking at architectural visualization
the dynamic range and the quality of the
images is actually what makes the
difference now you can zoom into both
these images i didn't spend an absurd
amount of time on either of them to be
able to compare them like by like but at
the end of the day from a rendering
point of view from a photorealistic
point of view from an editing point of
view the images produced out of unreal
engine 5 are still miles apart from what
twin motion can produce so to wrap this
video up it isn't going to be a long one
at all today twin motion or unreal
engine 5. well personally i think unreal
engine 5 is able to produce some
incredible renders it might even be able
to produce some of the best
architectural renders i've ever seen
probably not by me probably by somebody
a lot more experienced in unreal engine
than i am
for me personally i'll probably stick to
twin motion for a little while longer
just because it is a significantly
easier and less time consuming product
and then outsource or work with a
professional who knows unreal engine 5
significantly better to be able to
produce those photorealistic renders
when the time is required for you on the
other hand if you're looking to start in
one of these two softwares personally my
recommendation would be start with
unreal engine 5
yes it's got a steep learning curve yes
it's going to take you weeks if not
months to be able to understand the
basics and fundamental criteria to be
able to produce a half decent render on
unreal engine but those skills are going
to be transferable further in life
you're going to be able to do a lot more
with that rendering quality and you're
most likely even going to be able to
make a career out of it if that's
something that you're looking for so
between the two softwares yes twin
motion phenomenal can produce half
decent results but unreal engine 5 has
just stepped it up or not anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure you smash
that like button down below and don't
forget about the subscribe button now
like always i'll see you next monday